they need help yeah they need help um
isn't the quran a help well it is the
book that he's doing it is it is the
cure for him but he's licking it he's
supposed to read it and read it and
understand it licking it doesn't help
look i love the quran
look at me look at me as i lick the
quran was jesus a muslim hundred percent
he says look i worship god
fair khan
the nation have you heard of the nation
in kuntu
if i would have said it you would have
known it bismillah alhamdulillah
assalamu alaikum greetings and peace
welcome to the dean show ahmed your host
subscribe if you haven't already hit
that notification bell and my next guest
coming up
here on the dean i'm very excited we
have imam sheikh kareem
abu zayd he's an imam a lecturer an
educator he moved to the united states
20 years ago from egypt he spent the
last over 25 years studying his team he
has a master's a phd all those degrees
that you need he's got him and he's here
with us on the dean's show to cover
very important topic that we're going to
be talking about the quran we'll be
right back
[Music]
people are you ready
[Music]
go ahead and subscribe right now hit
that notification bell help us get our
numbers back up did you know that
many years ago the dean's show when we
started 2006 we used to broadcast for
many years on the khalifa clothing
channel currently known as digital
minbar so we're trying to get our
numbers back up because the channel at
that time got closed then we started the
official d show channel we're trying to
get our numbers back up to where they
should be
and that's this number here 855 combined
what we currently have 442 we should be
over a million subscribers help us to
get our numbers back to where they
should be with that small setback that
we had many years ago you guys can help
us by subscribing right now and hitting
that notification bell thank you very
much enjoy the rest of this show
and don't forget to support us on our
patreon page so going over 30 years now
yeah yeah all right
how does it feel now being in this have
you uh you feel uh now coming up this
long more experience you know more uh
knowledge uh from when you started
definitely yeah you
maturity is maturity experience
yeah that's my question let me before
you so the difference between now having
the textbook knowledge and then what's
in between all of this experience and
hearing all the problems that people
have and then some things from the
beginning do it like do us like that but
now you've got to have more wisdom and
how how does that work it makes a big
difference to
uh
touch base with reality
and actually live
you know some hardships and
and grow out of it
it really helps you to help people
rather than being
you know just focused on on the theory
only when you have the practice with the
theory
it's very beneficial
i want to get into this topic
by first having you watch this video you
don't know what i'm going to show you
i'm going to get into this raw
and
i'm going to ask you to guess what do
you think happened to this individual
he's going to be talking about the quran
and i warn you
parental discretion is advised
you know you might not like some of the
things he might have to say right we've
seen this before but now i want you to
guess what's happened to this individual
after you watch this and hopefully some
lessons can be learned from others
who are thinking or try to do something
like pull this stunt like this this
individual
so let's get into this clip from the
religion of piss i mean peace the
religion of peace
allah is going to kill me
hidayah
no
no allah no i love the quran
look i love the quran
look at me look at me as i lick the
quran
look at me as i lick the quran
look at me
look at me as i read the quran
look at me as i read the quran
ah look at me look at me
all right so he goes on to do some
other disturbing things but
you know what's interesting usually you
pass this up you let it go you know it
just to see things like this but what do
you think what are your actions when you
see something like that
i feel sorry for him
but frankly
you know but this is not the first time
you know at the time of the prophet they
did more crazy things than that yeah oh
yeah i mean
the
you know they used to have a campaign
you know people used to come to mecca
all the time to perform hajjan umrah of
course following you know uh
innovative you know they added things as
innovations
to the tradition of ibrahim and smi
they used to have a campaign of
distributing cotton course of school
like whoever is coming to makkah they
they warn him about listening to the
quran and they give him a free cotton to
place in his ears so he doesn't hear the
quran
you know this is a similar um
uh you know situation uh but it it
really incites you to feel sorry for the
guy because you know what ended up
happening to him why this came up
because he's actually from chicago well
he's not originally from chicago but he
was staying in chicago so this caught my
attention because he's from the city
where you're in right now
and he was in the news because he was
arrested
for
pedophilia for
pornography
well you know it's it's sad you know
people like those are troubled you know
they
may allah guide them or like this is the
one thing that they
so a lot of times you'll see you'll see
people out there who are projecting this
hate
you know a lot of times it's from
something internal they're pushing it
out but most of these people who are out
there we don't have to name any names
but many of them who have pretty big
followings right i don't know if you've
maybe debated some of them or whatnot
but you'll see like at the end when you
you have their lives exposed you know i
mean you see like really sick
individuals doing sick and then they get
caught out you know what i mean they
need help yeah they need help um isn't
the quran a help well it is the book
that he's doing it is it is the cure for
him but he's licking it he's supposed to
read it and read it and understand it
licking it doesn't help so maybe now if
he ever like gets out of jail now
he sees this this
may allah make him hear
the truth again and
i i think people like those i tell you
they they are very close to islam
because they are at the verge of
breaking their life you know destroying
their lives and
at one stage they they see the light you
know and
you you actually can be so hopeful for
this guy to be a muslim than anyone else
that you may you know consider wow
that's a
it is a different perspective yeah yeah
he's he's at the verge now yeah like i
mean we've seen it i mean people who are
really uh
so much into islamophobia they
subhanallah
they may accept islam and
may allah guide him that's that's all
but it's sad you know to
i mean you shouldn't i mean if you hate
islam you shouldn't be doing that you
know
have you have you seen now in your
travels
you know with the temple the the pace
now with everything where you're at
you're you know getting to see a lot of
things here and a lot of different
things where is the level now of islam
bashing
you know what you're seeing the level of
islamophobia has it tempered down a
little bit is it high where are you what
are you seeing on the ground
i mean
for me really i don't pay attention to
it anymore
but something very interesting last
thursday
i was flying to uh
uh fort lauderdale i was having uh
a weekend in florida to teach and stuff
so
that was thanksgiving day
so
you know this is how i travel you know i
don't
i wear my thing i really look like very
very muslim
so you know i go through this
service to expedite my
you know going through the uh security
yeah it's called clear or something like
that so so the guy who's working for
clear you know
he he he he keeps telling me happy
thanksgiving yeah and i'll just look at
him and smile happy thanksgiving i just
look at him and smile
i mean i i don't i don't i don't say it
i don't celebrate that i don't and i
don't want to you know bash him about it
i just want to go in peace
so he insisted that how come you're not
answering me
i said man can't you tell that i'm a
muslim i have nothing to do with
thanksgiving i don't i don't i don't
celebrate thanksgiving
then he right away started oh thank you
for spreading positive energy thanks
here i started you know oh that's what
you want to hear from me you know so you
know
if you know those people will always
exist but don't we celebrate
thanksgiving every day i mean
thanksgiving to the creator that heavens
and earth that we're thankful for him
guiding us that we're thankful for the
blessing so isn't for muslims life it's
giving thanks and praise to the creator
every day we thank allah every second of
the day
but we don't say thanksgiving we don't
have a turkey i mean we don't do that
that's you know that's mimicking
non-muslims
a lot of uh native americans they don't
celebrate thanksgiving do they
well
i i don't care what native americans do
or don't but because the history a lot
of people when they go into history
listen i'm a muslim yeah i have two
holidays yes
the prophet told me that i'm going to
stick to that yeah
you know
people try to justify that that's not a
religious thing that's
you know it's all about this it's your
business you know
you need to understand that allah
subhanahu wa
giving you the identity of a muslim
that's who you are stick to it
don't don't try to
you know
make up excuses to
uh mimic other people
was jesus a muslim hundred percent
i mean i'm a follower of jesus and jesus
was a muslim yes 100 but if someone says
he never heard that word before how do
you answer that what do you mean his own
disciples when they you know when he
asked them
you know when prophet jesus peace be
upon him
felt like the community is about to plot
to kill him he said who can support me
the disciples his disciples said we are
the supporters of allah
we believe in allah
you testify
we are muslims
his followers are muslims so jesus is
not a muslim
that's what it says
islam is a submission
that you submit
that you give up your choices
when allah subhanahu wa allah tells you
to do a certain thing
i'm not going to choose i'm going to go
with the choice of allah
that's what islam is about the concept
itself
he was a muslim
like all the previous messengers we've
heard this um that the lord's prayer in
there there's islam or our father in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come thy will be done is this islam
that's islam
in the lord's prayer yeah yeah it's
it's the essence
nothing will happen unless allah wills
for it to happen
he has a very profound statement in this
regard he said
whatever you will o allah will happen
even if i don't will it
and if i will something if you do not
will for it to happen it will never
happen
that's
the essence
that is why imam ahmad said
believe in mashiach
believe in allah his divine will which
is al-qatar
is
the system of monotheism
that you always link
your will with allah's will
so you love jesus
dearly
i love him so much some muslims but i
love him the way allah wants me to love
him
that i don't place him
ahead of allah
see that's that's what
the prophet warned us against
don't exaggerate regarding the status of
a created being
but
still call him the slave of allah and
his messenger
you see
love can be
deceiving
and
you know the first type of
polytheism shirk which emerged
into earth was circle
that the shirk in that area that you
actually end up loving someone but more
than allah
then you place them ahead of allah
subhana wa
and that's actually that's why you
should feel sorry for the christians
because they've fallen into that type of
shirk because it's very hard they love
christians love jesus but the wrong way
how's that pastor who visits your church
allah very nice man you have a good
relationship with him david david if you
come and listen
he
that's something like people doesn't
allah god almighty say in i mean in
in the quran that those closest to you
yeah are the christians well but you
have to how do you understand that and
that goes back to
understanding
those who say that we are christians are
closer
to the believers
but you have you see that the problem is
a lot of people when they recite these
verses
that they don't finish up
you see
why
because
they have
learned people priests and monks and
they are not arrogant
look here is what they're missing
and when they hear what was revealed to
prophet muhammed
you will notice their eyes floating with
tears because they know in their hearts
that this is the truth
and they will believe
so they will end up being muslims
you understand but
is that like the uh the priests who were
there when heracles when they came
you know with the message prophet
muhammad sent in the message those
priests were there when they heard the
quran they're crying you're talking
about the rajashi right no no heracles
yeah where he said that oh yeah yeah
he said he would if if prophet muhammad
was there he'd wash his feet well the
the
heracles is heracles is the one who said
that yeah not the you know not the
actually his priest stood against him
yes they they actually come on stop now
you know but they knew it at first they
were
yeah you see look at the description of
these verses they are not arrogant
they they they will if they know it's
the truth they will follow it but those
are the people who are close to you
because a lot of people they use this
verse to you know we're not inciting any
hate or any animosity against anybody
here but
you need to understand this
the jews and the christians will not be
pleased with you unless you follow their
way
so if a christian insists on following
his way he's going to wish for you to
follow his way even though his harm is
not identical to you're getting that
yeah but these verses you're referring
to those are people who accepted islam
they became muslims because you conveyed
the truth to them but we're following
the way we should insist more because
we're following more the way and we
emphatically say this with love you know
towards jesus that we're following his
way more because 100 percent this is
what jesus preached he never called
people to worship himself you know to
worship you know his mother to worship
god as a trinity look at the scene on
the day of judgment
allah
mentioned this scene which will happen
on the day of judgement look at this
the fourth verse before the last in a
chapter called
chapter 5.
allah will ask jesus peace be upon him
in front of his followers so-called
followers actually they are followers of
paul
the the the pauline theology the
distorted theology so allah will ask
jesus in front of them did you command
your people those people to take you and
your mother as two gods beside allah
he will say glory be to you you're above
that
how can i say something like that which
is i'm entitled to do i'm not entitled
to do
in
if i would have said it you would have
known it
you know that which
inside me inside my nest and i don't
know what's inside yourself
and you are the knower of the unseen.
i only convey to them what you commanded
me to convey and
worship allah your lord and my lord
that's his message
and subhanallah
something so amazing
that the first words that came out of
his mouth as a baby in the cradle
the scene is overwhelming and surrounded
by jesus jesus words out of his mouth
out of his mouth as a baby you know when
when
uh you know when when maryam mary
delivered him yeah so now she became
concerned because at the time having a
baby out of woodlock this is a big no
in in that society at the time
of course allah comforted her and he
said
you know
jesus the baby
you're from the lineage of aaron aaron
is the brother of musa
now this is in the quran this is in the
quran this is the this is what they call
the nativity this is the nativity story
the virgin the quranic version of the
nativity story
they said
this chapter maryam beautiful chapter
maryam
how can we talk to
an infant who was just born in the
cradle look
abdullah
the first words
i'm the slave of allah
at any
i need guidance like you
you see he giving me the book because i
need all sorts of guidance i need to
to learn
and he made me a prophet
mubarak
and he made me blessed wherever i am the
scholar said regarding blessed meaning
that i enjoy good and forbid evil i see
evil i have to speak about it
i have that's what mubarak and blessed
whatever
i need to pray too
because that's the spiritual nutrition
for the soul i need to pray like you
i'm in need
but salah
and i need to purify myself to madame
and i will be beautiful to my mom you
know the subhanallah uh eddie
there is a a verse
which really uh you know finishes up
this debate
in in in the quran in chapter
two yeah you know regarding what's this
worse
is a messenger who came in a chain of
messengers
and his mother was a truthful woman look
at this here it is
they used to eat they both ate food yes
you see if you eat that means you need
that means you're weak
and
allah is above that
allah is about subhanallah that's why we
say subhanallah meaning what allah is
above that glory be to allah allah is
above that allah is free of needs jews
and christians also for our guests who
might be tuning in who are you know from
your part of the world egypt or
any other arab speaking country they use
the word allah right yeah yeah it's
mentioned 17 times in the first page in
the old testament the book of genesis in
the book of genesis the first page 17
times they use allah
jews and arabic jews and arabic jews and
arabic christians yes so what what do
you say for people who will say that
okay muhammad sallallahu salaam
he ended up he took this from the jews
and the christians you know he used to
travel a lot you hear this what do you
say that is why it's a key
to believe that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was illiterate
before
some muslims by the way you know they
they don't understand that that's that's
the first point yeah he could not
read no way right he wasn't educated no
way yeah even though he was the most
intelligent
right
meaning meaning that because of the
revelation that's coming is that correct
with this perfect narratives
no way
also
you know i i did the
first volume sierra in canterbury
my book my first volume
in the last chapter of this book i
addressed this issue
the illiteracy of the prophet salallahu
and i mentioned there is no way
that the prophet sallam would have
access to such
wealth of literature that's the second
point so again he was not someone who
knew how to read and write that's
established fact the people of his
vicinity locality the people at that
time testify to that right also the the
text was not translated yet to arabic
that's the second point yes and it was
not available in the arrangement so the
christian text jewish text that was not
available available accessible
at that time
who when you bring up to omar dillahun
they had said they had some of the
talmud
well
you know that that that actually in
support of uh you know the uh
uh purity of the our revelation yeah uh
the story of omar that you know one day
he brought verses
beautiful how do you
understand that
you see the
uh omar one day he had a jewish
companion that rabbi he used to hang
around with in medina yeah
and omar used to be attracted to the
fact that a lot of similarities between
the quran
and the old testament yeah
you know the
i mean
some of them are almost identical except
these human touches
you know
so one day he brought verses to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam which
are similar look at rasulallah
the prophet became upset yeah and his
face turned red
and and he said
this is a mixed up
their literature is a mixed up
is not pure it has certain things that
got changed it's been tampered with it's
been tampered with yes
you know it's been it's been mass
distorted in a way
because of the human interference into
the
whether in a form of translation or
whether in a form of
changing and you have bible scholars who
testified yes they know that i mean it's
it's it's it's it's a fact
so the prophet said instead of you going
to a source that is
you know
messed up tampered with like you
mentioned
just stick to the purity of my
you know as if the you know and
subhanallah this is a big issue when you
use their own textbook to to make up you
know points and allah you have the quran
the quran is pure the quran is clean the
quran is perfect and that's the wisdom
of the quran being sent no because now
you had the previous revelations they
were tampered with changed right and
they were for a suited time and period
right quran is for the end of time till
the end of the time you see these camper
free tempered proof you see
prior to the prophet salallahu
were privileged with
the presence of a messenger two or three
at the same time
always they have people
so if the guidance is tampered with but
they have a living model subhanallah can
you imagine that yeah the uh prophet
around them amongst them
i'm saying can you imagine living during
the time you have a messenger right
there yeah but
because we were the bride from this
privilege yeah allah preserved the quran
for us
you're getting that yes yes you see our
messenger was labeled really important
point yeah so because of that
now being applied at that time you had
the messengers right time who were able
to correct anything i mean sometimes you
would have three messengers in is like
the story of the village and chatter you
seen it
we send to them two messengers
they believe them
then we sent the third one
imagine having a three prophets at the
same time in your town
that we as muslims we were that
privilege was taken away from us because
of the fact
that our messenger was called the final
but in lieu of this allah
vowed to preserve the quran
that's why you know when you hear
somebody saying the quran the narrative
has holes in it he's like man you know
that's a that's akida issue
you know that's a believe matter you
know when when you claim that the the
quran has that narrative and and stuff
it has a hole in it that
you you you need to check your belief
system here because that's very
dangerous very dangerous because you
must believe that this must-have is
preserved
now
without even
being convinced about the techniques or
the method even though we can share the
method and how it was preserved we know
how you know i i mentioned in in my book
the makhan
but
in a way you have it's a i believe
matter that you must be firm on it that
the quran is perfect
you're getting that yes so
in the absence of of prophets and and
and messengers because our messenger is
the last
we have the guidance we have the
revelation and that is why it's a key to
connect with the quran again someone
asked you what's the difference between
your guys religion and now islam
where okay it's just faith at the end
it's blind faith because most people
like when you get down to the
nitty-gritty of certain religions
i disagree what do you say well
islam doesn't it it's not blind faith no
actually islam is initiated on
intellectual
see that's for this is your you're
getting a lot of people's interest well
because you know the person says look
when it comes down to my religion let's
say for the trinity at the end when i
dig dig dig and i push the pastor he
says look you just got to believe just
have faith islam inspires you incites
you to look around
look at these words have they not looked
effelent
have they not looked at the camels how
they are created
and to the heaven how it is raised up
with our pillars
and to the mountains
have they not seen the heaven how
beautiful with the stars
now anyone
intellectual here should ask who made
that
you didn't make it did did you make that
creation eddie did you no human being
could have done no actually this existed
before us
to begin with and that's what allah says
in surah
you see allah created everything in how
many days in six days guess who was
created the last element of the if the
creation was created last who
who adam
so the heaven and the earth existed
before before our father
you know you need to understand so you
come into this world and you see ah
you know
they asked a big one
how in the world do you believe in there
is a god
you know
he said
if i see a dung of a camel that means
there was a camel here even though i do
not see a camel you know what i don't
know if a camel is right yes
and if i see the
the foot the the feet the printing
the feet in the ground in the desert
even though i do not see the person but
now i know that there was someone here
look at this
the heaven with all these beautiful
stars
are
the earth with all these valleys and the
mountains you came to colorado how
beautiful it is
the oceans with all these waves
this doesn't tell you that there is a
god it seems like this better is more
intelligent a lot of times than
the academics in the university yeah
yeah so he's applying common sense but
it's a shame that's intellectual common
sense is not common practice now that's
an intellectual statement yeah that's a
very in-depth intel intellect
that you see when you look around you
eddie
and and and and you look into this world
you you come up with with two
conclusions i wrote this in my book know
your lord i have a book called know your
lord i wrote this in this
you come up with there must be a creator
because if you don't believe there is a
creator then there's something wrong
with you intellectually
were they created out of nothing and
that goes to the atheist you know if you
really want to answer an atheist just
tell him that verse and sora
were they created out of nothing or did
you create yourself
both are no
so there must be what creator a creator
now
logically
the creator
has to be
better or greater in attributes than the
created
are you going to make the created and
the creator equally equal
are you going to equate them equally no
that's in the quran
is the one who creates equals the one
who does not create
now what are the attributes
and the qualities of the creator
grab your intellect now
put it in your pocket and go to the
revelation
now you stop now everything led you with
the faculties that god almighty allah
gave you you use your senses
he is your intellect now now you have to
submit now now you got to the true
submit
there are there are messengers and
prophets allah sent to this world and
they were supported with miracles
they came to convey this message of who
is your lord who is allah yes know your
lord through the revelation you can't
use intellect
to figure out allah you cannot do that
that's that's a beautiful thing about
islam submission to the creator not the
creation now you're believing in this
whole chain
of messengers that came adam being the
first man then noah abraham
ishmael isaac it's a beautiful photo and
they all came with the same exact same
message worship one and one
it puts you in total harmony with the
whole world yeah with the universe you
don't have to have this no confusion in
your mind it makes sense everything
makes sense based on proof of evidence
do you have other pastors like
obviously there's something about
yourself the community islam mainly
because david he keeps showing up
and do others do you have other
experience with other christian pastors
who like you know
coming you have a respectful
relationship with that you have a
connection with in the community i
always have a respectful relationship
even with the people who don't like
islam
because at the end of the day you know
you're not there to force people to
believe yeah you're there eddie to
establish the evidence
to witness over them
i conveyed the truth to you
and i think david respects you and
others because you're not like you know
uh
sugar coating things and twisting things
and some people they like you know twist
things just to get people through the
door but then people find out man this
guy lied to me you know what i mean it's
like a car salesman he told you all this
like
stuff you want to hear and the car's
breaking down you tell them how it is
huh
well i i think and i think that he
respects you for people respecting
somebody sometimes it doesn't go down
well for a lot of people when you talk
about i think
people deserve to hear the truth
and you know i think this video is going
to be released around you know we see
all these lights
your children ask you what these lights
are about and
christmas and you know and jesus and
of course it has nothing to do with
really the tradition but
you know your neighbor your co-worker
deserves to hear the truth the truth
from allah
you know don't sugar quote things you
know
being tolerant with people
is in the area of interacting with them
that i'm going to be just and fear to
you
i'm going to treat you with respect
but i'm not going to tell you that
you're going to heaven
because i believe you're going to hell
i mean in the sense i believe that in my
heart because
tolerance is not in beliefs tolerance is
an interaction with people you know and
because at the end of the day they get
to choose allah giving you see getting
to believe is a god giving right to
people you can take it away from them
no compulsion you cannot compel people
you know likewise a devout christian
probably believe that i'm going to hell
too because i don't believe in his form
enough salvation
so if someone this is something now if
jesus at his time moses had his time you
know they would
say message look if you worship
other than the creator it's in the bible
right also there if you set up partners
this to god you worship a false god this
is a one-way ticket to the healthcare
hellfire even us
if we
um go ahead and deny jesus
can a muslim end up
having a one-way ticket was the reaction
of prophet moses
and the biblical moses
when he returned to his people and he
found them worshiping the calf
in the desert that's in the old
testament
they can't deny that
what was his reaction
he was upset
he was very upset
i mean
you see that the mission of the
messengers and the prophets
is to invite people
to single out allah
is made of negation
you have to cancel out
everything
jesus is not a god the star is not a god
the man is not a god the tree is not a
god the mountain is not a god and then
you say that god is allah the one who
deserves to be worshiped worthy of my
worship and obedience is allah
why because he created me
he provides for me
you know he's he's the one who who gives
me what i have
you know people worship that created
things and the creative things are in
need
what about
fair khan you know he says look i
worship god a lot of fair khan sarah the
nation have you heard of the nation they
call it the nation the nation of islam
yeah but uh some people say they really
missed islam and look again no
disrespect to uh him or you know his uh
group but a lot of those uh people who
are part of the nation imam saraj wahad
jim qasim khan many who are captains
there malcolm x they all when they were
exposed to the real islam they came and
they accepted islam so what would you
say to someone like that farrakhan
himself
and would you have a sit down ever with
him if he invited you
and for the people who are confused
because that's a big misconception a lot
of times the general public when you
talk about islam
because they have a big following here
in in america so now especially in the
urban communities nothing like are these
guys nation are they you guys come on
have you ever had this happen to you
yeah
yeah 100 yeah you see um
it's because this goes back to tafsir
understanding the quran islam islam is
crystal clear
you cannot
attribute
divinity to anybody
the source of revelation is the quran
and the sunnah
and you stick to the understanding of
the first three generations yeah that's
it
anyone else who comes in and he says i i
receive
you know
then
leave this alone i'm a prophet like the
nation you know they claim that you know
would you a lot of them like to
to
have talks and you know i've had many
contact with me would you be willing to
talk with anyone have you ever talked to
someone from the nation yes i did yes
how does that go how does something like
that go
i think
don't they go into the bible and they go
into all sorts of to kind of prove their
case you know i'm going to give you the
essence of their issues yes
because unfortunately you know
most of the people i came in contact
with
they are established
members of that
of the nation of the nation yeah
you know the moment that your livelihood
relies
on
it's very hard
you know
you know this is
um that is why the prophet salallahu
said to the jewish rabbis at his time
you know if
10 of those people will accept islam the
rest will
and that's why they receive two rewards
the people who are followers of previous
faith they receive two rewards why
because a lot of them have to give up
their status
you know he's being followed
by masses by people
now you have to give this up and become
a follower
so you got to go from
having uh following to being a follower
exactly
it's like you know like many of the fan
you know they're the facebook fan kind
of speakers you know they have like
millions of followers
and these followers followed them on on
foundations of music is okay
mixing is okay
now when they are asked these questions
they are not going to answer them but
but you had also others who came look
malcolm x he ended up you know somewhere
you know when allah wills guidance for
anybody allah will guide
you know and that's really where you
need to
settle
you know allah is the one who knows who
deserves guidance
right i mean
oh i mean there are figures out there in
my opinion the most impressive story
that i love to
read from
this malcolm yeah malcolm what do you
say because now they're one of their
main beliefs because people say you know
they've come they've made some
adjustments like the i think the uh the
fasting now from doing it i believe when
they used to do it under savior's day
now they switched it over if i'm not
mistaken uh they fast during the month
of ramadan uh the prayer but now this
fraud muhammad you know they have
believed that this
pakistan
an individual
he ended up becoming god allah they say
he was allah
so and they do you think they are still
muslims this way no
no
i mean this is not to show any uh
disrespect to them right this is out of
the love to help them god willing uh
inshallah to come all the way
you know because you could be doing all
those things but now if you say that
you're just reading the quran
islam is symbol
is already there it's preserved now
follow the understanding of the first
three generations that's where i think
they must miss the vote you can't make
up your own but how did they get past
surah how do you get past
because before he approached the surah
yeah the chapter which is crystal clear
this is like where are you going with he
already had a preconceived beliefs yeah
already
so
anything that negate that that cancels
out or refutes
he
will be reluctant to accept it
again if he is established in this world
on the basis of that religion
when this is one of the main obstacles
which stood in the way of the jewish
rabbis at the time of the prophet to
accept islam
because they were established
but someone like abdullah ibn islam for
example you know the first jewish rabbi
who accept islam right i mean he he was
willing to give up
his status his position because of the
truth
there are many like this
but not many people are willing to give
up the world which they already built
and they invested in
i have all these followers
i am going to give this up for this
see that's where his test of faith is
you know that's where you get tested
uh let's jump into uh back to this one
uh about jesus uh peace be upon him
there was uh
a
woman who was she called in and she was
asking she's really close to accepting
islam but she was stuck she wanted more
clarification like what's the quran mean
what happened to jesus
because they say it's a historical event
that he ended up dying right they say he
was crucified but then the quran and
she's confused that okay if someone was
replaced an image of him and how how
does the actual you know how do you like
to explain this situation
we have uh athar abdullah ibn abbas
which is really the
you know
that when prophet
is the one who combined this other it's
authentic
that when jesus peace be upon him
uh already felt like they are advancing
uh to come and grab him and and execute
him
he stood up and he delivered a short
sermon this is what they refer to the
last supper you know where the wine
isn't but this is our virgin here
and he said
what will happen and he has to go and
all of that
but who amongst you
would accept that my likeness would be
thrown on him
now we're getting this from
from
abbas it's authentic the statement of
abdullah ibn abbas this is the company
is the cousin of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam this is number one
number two the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam made very special invocation
for him he said
o allah
teach him the interpretation of the
quran of the book
but but we have to be very careful
because some of them are weak you have
to look at the chain of transmitters
make sure that this is one of the
generating is authentic
yeah yeah the chain is authentic yes so
he's saying okay let's start with the
quran what does the quran say and then
he's giving ex to jesus of the quran
yes the tafseer of the quran
here is the verse
and and regarding jesus regarding jesus
in a chapter number four surah
i can give you the number later
is talking about the jew the jewish
community
who rejected the message of prophetess
because they disbelieved and they
uttered
uh
allegation against maryam that she got
jesus out of woodlock
that she did adultery now yes she
foreign
and because of their utterance
that we killed
the messiah the christ isa
the messenger of allah look at this now
they killed him not uh
they crucified him not
walekin should be
but they were made to see that
that's where abdullah ibn abbas comes to
explain
he said when they approached
the location where prophet isa was
hanging out with his disciples
he allah allah informed him that they
are coming to grab you to execute you so
he stood up and he delivered the sermon
short sermon
the last supper yes
but i mean there is no wine in there
right yeah so
so he said who amongst you
would sacrifice
that my likeness will be thrown on your
face
and you will be crucified in my place
and you will be my companion in jannah
the youngest of them stood up
now some people may have the right to
ask this companion just one second said
me o messenger of god yes he said oh
messenger yes rasulullah not saying god
says no no no no
he said to them allah will raise me up
and i so that there is another messenger
will be coming and then i will come
after him to complete
his work yeah that's his second coming
but here it is
christians or anybody who hears this
has the right to ask
why did this have to happen this way why
this scenario because i tell you why
this scenario because would jesus have
been risen up taken up by allah
to the heaven without this scenario
the jewish community would have killed
all his disciples
because they would be looking for him
they are not going to believe that he
was taken up
right they don't believe he's a
messenger to begin with yeah so now
they're going to say where's jesus
oh he went up
come on
so they're going to execute all of them
now who will spread the teachings of
jesus
after him
the disciples so that disciples have to
stay alive so that's why the jewish
community has to be convinced that they
gotten rid of jesus
you're getting that yeah that makes a
lot of sense so and this is what
happened you see when when when when
these disciples survived this hardship
they went around and they spread what
his teachings but around what around the
area where jesus was sent to you see
jesus was not a universal message
messenger
jesus was sent to many israel even some
you know in the new testament some guy
came from
the gentile asking him a question he
said no i was sent to the lost
sheep of the house of israel i'm not
you know so
so the disciples stayed in jerusalem
you know to teach to spread his
teachings and they succeeded
they kept the fort for a while
until the self-claimed disciple pulled
you know some guy who you know
like the
extreme sufis kind of experienced he
said i saw light you know some people
like in the muslim world they say i saw
light that's what he said he saw a light
i saw a light there and somebody's
sitting out there and telling me but
it's just like you know accepting uh
hitler after he persecuted you know the
jews will and then saying that he got
revelation would they accept him as a
messenger well look what cause he was a
bounty hunter look what he thought
wasn't he yeah he was a bounty hunter
yeah he was killing the kids yes yes yes
i made that example like let's say
for instance was doing that and which he
was and then he came here here's what
i'm looking for and that's what every
christian should
should read in the book of corinthians
that paul
became so famous in cyprus and southern
italy
his teachings his distorted teachings of
christianity became so famous
that they invited him you know when you
hear that there is this famous scholar
in america let's invite him to come and
give a speech yeah but right now you
could go online and listen to some of
his speeches ah this guy is fake man
this guy is not real he doesn't teach
quran and sunnah then you cancel out his
trip but at the time he's a famous guy
who's walking around spreading them
but they don't know that he's giving up
distorted the
the
the doctrine of atonement the sacrifice
the the foundation for the trinity so
they invited him to jerusalem to give a
talk in the book of corinthians the
first book
maybe you can look at i'll show you the
source there they chased him out of the
jerusalem
he got chased out because of the
teaching what are you teaching this has
nothing to do with the people call them
out these are learned people those are
the learned people yeah imagine like
what a david pastor when you tell the
pastors there's a christian
what does he say you know subhanallah
allah got this guy but i think one day
he's going to be a muslim in charlotte
the pastor yes yes he's a very nice man
he's he really he's really into it he
keeps coming back i think that's he's
going through a struggle jihad himself
yes right i think he's
he has so many followers
uh behind him and he wanted to be sure
that
subhanallah you know he comes and he
writes what i say yeah
i see him writing recording and even
after the hotmail he asked me you said
that word in harabi i didn't get it
you know
so what did you mean by that so
so maybe so go back to now this um
situation with paul what were you saying
so the bottom line here is here you are
you brought the the guy that the
christians now following
and he was face to face with the
disciples
of jesus
barnabas is one of the disciples of
jesus the one who saved you walked him
out come on this guy is going to kill
you man
about james his brother jesus yeah
they chased him out what are you
teaching
what is this this has nothing to do with
what jesus told the pure message yes
you see he he he came up with with more
of a
idol worship kind of you know
formula and that is that is why it
received a very good uh acceptance or
the acceptance was very good in in
europe but but look at the end of the
day uh uh eddie you know uh this what
i'm trying to say is
you got two theologies evolving
progressing in in the roman empire
because palestine jerusalem at the time
was under the reign of the roman empire
actually the blooding to crucify jesus
was in between the jewish
community
and the
the emir the leader of jerusalem at the
time who was appointed by the reckless
you know hercules so
you got those two
brands of christianity evolving
progressing
until they started clashing
they ended up clashing yeah
it's like the sunni you know
very close to that you know so the the
emperor constantine
constantine the emperor
the year 318.
his mom was more into the pole
his mother constantine's mother yeah so
he said i don't want this conflict this
religion the religious conflicts in in
my empire
he gathered all the christian
theologians from both
sects
from both groups
in a place called nicaea
which is turkey now istanbul
it was his summer
break you know where he goes and spend
the summer
and he placed him inside the room and he
said you're not coming out until you
figure out who's jesus
is he the son
or is he just a messenger is he
subhanallah the
people
the pauline because the politics come to
play
that's one of the most dangerous things
when the imperial power interfere with
faith and the whole environment if you
can paint the picture the whole
environment is a pagan vibe vegan
vitamin you see whatever goes
closer to paganism is easier sell yeah
it was appealing
yeah you know like they they want to do
now with you know the imperial powers is
working
hard now to actually influence islam you
need to know that too they want to
create that new brand of islam
you know and and people in
governments are investing money
to come up with this abrahamic you know
that one
religion thing and all of that but they
don't understand that this is not going
to happen because
the
guidance is preserved you see in allah's
divine
knowledge
allah knew that after jesus there will
be another messenger who will come and
rectify things finish what happens now
so there so basically basically he said
to the
the over 300 of them they were there
they said agree i want you to come out
with one religion not two
so what were the two they're deciding
one group is saying that jesus is uh is
a messenger they're not claiming the
disciples and the teachings of the
disciples he's the messenger of allah
he's the slave of allah he came to call
people to submit to allah there is a day
of judgment
that's what we believe in we believe in
now yeah that's us yeah yeah he is
muslims okay so then the other version
is what
the trinity he died for your sins
yeah so the other one is the doctrine
just that alone tells you something yeah
right you see what i'm saying just that
alone that there's the debate with all
these heads at that time the beginning
now
of when all this happened what that
should tell the intelligent person like
hold on advisor even this debate by the
way this is history
these things are history it's not
something like that when making up yeah
actually we got this from their own
books yeah
their own narratives now you can try to
explain it away as much as you want but
yeah you know it's straightforward
common sense why is there this debate
now why is there this group there's the
group they're in there right right
they're saying no these earlier sources
you know the earlier groups the ones
closest to jesus right around him
they're saying just like the sahabah
those are his companions yeah that is
why uh you know that's why you know when
i say quran and sunnah based on the
understanding of who
his disciples
companions disciples likewise us right
we you see the prophet said what
dividing is a is a
being
sects groups
is
something that is ordained by allah that
is why the prophet said the jews divided
into 71 groups
the christians divided into 72 groups
and you will divide into 73 groups guess
who's the group that's
those who follow the understanding of
the disciples the companions
but look at any sects in islam they
whether follow someone who just came
recently farahan or farahan or
hallowhan or shahuhan or all this
none of them will say abu bakr said of
man said uh omar said
you won't see the nation fair khan they
won't say
because that would destroy
their
theology
100
you see
that's why we say the quran and the
sunnah based on the understanding of the
first three generations of muslims that
makes total sense for anybody who's
using common sense because i often say
give this example likewise i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm going to interrupt you
likewise jesus jesus you see follow the
teachings of jesus based on the
understanding of the people who learned
from him
the disciples not paul paul never met
jesus
never met jesus in his life
he was actually one of the like he said
bounty huh hunter he used to kill
his his followers for for money
i want people to understand this is very
important because if you're living with
someone you're best friends with someone
for 10 20 30 years they're using a
certain language lingo whatever the case
you'll understand it better than someone
a thousand
five hundred fourteen hundred years
later right so you now there's so it's
logical this is where it's called logic
yeah so there's gonna be so many things
you don't understand i often say the
thing like someone tells you to go hurry
up you know break a leg you know and you
know you know you know break a leg means
no
you don't see i see right now imagine if
i yeah if now someone's telling me break
a leg hurry up i'm from it means hurry
up yeah yeah i'm from the wilderness i'm
from egypt but now you don't know that
and now you and your zeal you go
breaking legs
you follow me
so you can see where there's room for
all this mis hundred percent
interpretation so that just makes sense
those who around him the disciples of
jesus
the disciples of synonymous we say
companions we could say disciples also
can we say that look yes disciple look
what the prophet said
the best of the muslims
the best of mankind is the people who
lived at my time
then those who learned from them
than those who learned from them
three generations this is hadith this
hadith is narrated by over 10 companions
different chains
different chains of narrations it was
narrated by 10 companions imagine that
that's
and and when when the prophet sallam
uh
mentioned that muslims will divide like
the christians like the jews
he said all of those people are in hell
except one
whether they are in hell for eternity or
not that's we can debate that later on
you know based on what they came up with
but
accept one the companions ask who are
those
those who follow
my understanding and my disciples
understanding of islam
that's it can be crystal clear then
likewise exactly right here that's what
we're trying to tell our friends
from the christian world that
listen paul was presented face to face
in the book of corinthians go read it in
the book
face to face with jesus students with
the disciples of jesus with the
companions of jesus
they didn't accept what he is saying
he was saying you don't have to
you can eat pork no dietary restrictions
you don't have to be circumcised
you know
all of that they they chased him out get
this guy out of here you know like when
when you have a self you kind of as [ __ ]
and you bring some guy to talk about
you know sufi experience and stuff i
mean guess what will happen to him i
mean i mean this is like beside the
point
so you have now his disciples you know
and you go back if someone's sincere and
they're humble and they really want to
know the truth and they go look at this
i mean a lot of the stuff is
self-evident i mean but like you said if
you have invested interest you have a
position right and if you made this
imaginary concept in your mind
and now you have god almighty like a
genie in a genie bottle you know what i
mean you just it's it's at the end of
the day allah places you you have to
choose
in many cases you know many people are
faced with this dilemma
you know like some guy who's established
in this world to
say certain things and all his facebook
fans are
they they are there because of that
thing yeah now
can he change it yes if he plays the
rada hereafter
in the scale with the dunya and he
chooses the achara
then he will change it
but if the dunya is still in his heart
but this is some people might take it
wrong i just want to clarify this you
know when we talk about this
can we say this is out of the love for
the christians out of the love for
people out there because in the quran
didn't god almighty allah is saying will
you kill yourself out of grief yeah we
muhammad that you know
this is out of love
you sent us a mercy to mankind by allah
we care for them
and that's why we're telling them the
truth
we care for them
you know we come to this country man i
mean i i came here as an you know
and we
this is really this is i feel what you
can give back to america
you know not only the religious front
the moral front look at the morality in
america where it's going down
you know they spoke to this brenda or
linda what's her name there yeah the
christian christian
yes
look what the morality is going through
you know this is where you think we can
we can work together yeah you know we
work together yeah on this front
morals because morality right now i mean
is is is going down the drain you know
the motor i mean what do you this really
exasperates me when we see like many of
the christians who are calling this out
also they're struggling with this you
know they want what we want for our
families but they're taking us as the
enemy a lot of times they're taking
muslims as the enemy islam is the enemy
but islam has all the solutions for this
we're not trying to the ones who try to
change your children into different
genders we're not the ones
it's
something that we share
intuition there are things certain
things which are shared between human
beings this is one of them this is
against the intuition the innate the
natural state upon which
you see when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said every person is
born
i know that you're going to say a muslim
but you can say born straight
yeah straight meaning what
he has a gender
now
the responsibility of the parents is to
protect that gender
now we live in a country
where parents are no more
responsible for that and actually they
their children can be taken away if they
interfere
based on what's happening there in
california that's what she told me that
they are trying to come up with a law to
say that if parents influence children
allah is telling you on the tongue of
his messenger that that the parents are
the one who protect the fitra
protect that straightness
now you're telling me the parents cannot
do that
i just had another guest it was so
important talking about this and they
were warning
a lot of these uh countries who have a
big muslim population
that the u.n
they were pushing and helping with this
sex ed sexual education packet right can
you imagine that and these are things
that many of the leaders they don't
read you know at the bottom of all the
stacks of what they have to sign so now
they give all these incentives you see
they they tied they tied everything into
economy yeah for you to receive aids
from the west you have to condone
our moral standards
which are not
in conformity with
our religious based moral standard
divine
see something about character and
morality allah is the one who decides
that because if it is left to the people
changes from one gender we just spoke
about maryam right maryam is is
mother jesus coming with a baby out of
good luck look at the reaction of the
community
you know imagine nowadays a christian
family their daughter will say i'm
pregnant and she's not married oh
congratulation that's
good for you do you know the baby's
gender
can we have a baby shower
so the morality what is
you are
on the best religion meaning the source
of the character is divine allah is the
one who decides what is right and what
is wrong
allah is the one who
legislates
these
boundaries what you cannot cross and
what you can cross
yeah so humans are
taking over
and they want us to follow and that's
why we were coming up with our own
education salahuddin future academy
insha allah safa usa we're trying to
save many children from
the environment the wicked
environment out there because it's no
longer safe for muslim children would
you say it's can you say it's and i'm
just going to be
as blunt here as possible because now
we don't really have time
we're losing the children would you say
it's borderline haram to send your
children
to the public institution hundred
percent wow you didn't even say fifty
percent
for doing that
allah is my witness i tell this to my
wives to my wife
there is an escame accidental here
i'd rather have my kids without any
education than sending them to these
institutions
you lose them they are gone
and a lot of christians are getting and
even the jewish community they they also
they understand this who started the
culture of home schooling in america
just ask this simple question
who christians devout christians yeah
yeah they're understanding what's
happening in the public schools yes
imagine you're sending your child to a
place where
your child hears
for 12 years k-12
you can be happy without god
god doesn't exist in your life
and all the textbook all the literature
is god is out
and then you wonder my son is
declaring that he's an atheist now
what do you mean i mean
you know he you know
subhanallah you know and that's why or
something that's beautiful that we did
with this we're working on that on
salahuddin that
that you know looking at the textbook my
daughter one time tells me what
my daughter you know she she read the
american textbook
genes define the gender and the color
of the child
genes
define that
marijuana
gene defined that maryam
gene defined that
that's haram to say that shirk right
here
shirk right here now now you're giving
genes the genially yeah
the
authority of allah say allah employs or
utilizes
that means to do that but allah is the
one who decides that
imagine this is just one line
in in science book
imagine the other
you know so you guys
you
cancel all this out well we can't cancel
it out because of accreditation you see
you see that you have to but what we did
is we
alerted the teacher
that this textbook is going to be there
but you have to alert the students you
educate them now you educate them
because
we're accredited school so we have to
still keep because we want our children
to go to colleges and you know study
carry on with their education right so
now we have to stick to accreditation
but what we did is in a listen plan we
designed the listen plan and the lesson
plan we said to the teacher going to
come across the textbook
you need now to let the children know
the truth so they can go to so if the
parents are hearing this for the first
time they're like what options do we
have they have salahuddin
future academy is
www safa
s-a-f-a that's the abbreviation for
salahaddin future academy safa
s-a-f-a
usa for america dot org
you go there you're gonna see the
curriculum you're gonna see you can
enroll your children you can end up
having your children learning from home
and by the way eddie we have live
instructors
we don't have like homeschooling like
the kids go into some software and no we
have live teachers who teach
and and you can do that or
you know uh
we encourage i'm actually to meeting
tomorrow in lombard machida to establish
a learning center here in there so if
anybody out there from the masjid's
wants to start a learning learning
center center yes with in collaboration
basically what we do is we we we
encourage you and this is actually what
we want this is actually the the
direction that we want to head to that
we encourage local communities to
group children
the same age possibly in one classroom
hire a tutor
a mentor
just to watch the children and make sure
that they are this you know discipline
they are keeping up with the instructors
in the other side and we give discount
for that by the way we give actually we
give special rate for that for learning
centers and you guys provide all the
materials you have the chromebook the
textbook the instructors that are so
easy
people are loving it
people are loving it we're having a lot
of good feedback alhamdulillah but we
still have ground to improve more
inshallah one more thing i wanted to ask
you about very important because we
started off talking about the verbatim
word of god almighty lord the quran last
and final revelation sent to mankind
anyone who is sincere open-hearted and
they want to know the truth they ask the
creator of heavens and earth guide me
god may guide me and they look at the
quran you actually can get it for free
at thedeenshow.com free copy of the
quran at thedeenshow.com
and now
from there you want the proper
understanding you gave the framework
right the quran and the authentic
sunnah hadith and understanding of the
companions and now you have this
actually in an audio version it's
beautiful talk about this i've been
trying to get the community anybody's
out there has a really good book put it
on audio inshallah if it meets the
standards we can try to help promote it
but you actually have an audio version
talk to us about well alhamdulillah
right now and i'm really very blessed to
allah that towards the end of my
journey
allah knows how long we'll be here
i'm i'm
really taken by the quran you know i'm
spending so much time and i'm loving it
you know
i wish i'm like him you know but that's
you know even
i'm not saying that i'm not here so that
people don't misunderstand but
i wish i i can you know
but you know when he was jailed in jail
so they took away all his books
all his he used to write in jail he used
to teach in jail
when they took away all his books from
him he was only left with the quran
which he memorizes
so he started reflecting upon the quran
and he said this is the best thing ever
happened to me
because they took away all my books i
can't write i can't read i can't produce
anything so what do i have in my chest
he memorizes the whole quran
so he could now review it and talk about
it and
you know subhanallah so i hope this is
the end i'd love to die on this so i
i'm working on on a trend of tafsir
which is called makasidik tafsir
what is mahasadektvsir is
you look at the
present-day
issue
like you know a very oppressive a very
um i'm sorry uh
uh
demanding issue is the issue of
pornography and you know and and
relevant contemporary issues that we're
dealing with right
and and you pick up one issue
then you go to the revelation based on
the understanding of the companions
and you look for verses that treated
this issue
and you try to explain it to the people
and you offer the remedy and the cure
yeah so alhamdulillah i came with volume
one which is the theory you know the the
concept
it's available now on on my website
kareemabazid.com you can actually
download it for free you can order it
from amazon and the book actually
available in audio format some brother
mashallah from england is named jalal
his name muhammad may allah reward him
he liked the book and he decided to
actually
do 11 hours on something of of the
entire book on audio format
so it's available also on my website
but alhamdulillah i'm working on
volume two inshallah which is al-fatiha
and then i'm working on volume three
also i finished the fatiha it's
with an editor i have a very good
brother who's editing my work his name
is jimmy abdullah he's a revert he loves
it mashallah is in minnesota
for alhamdulillah
this is a good thing you know i hope
i will finish the quran so inshallah
everything
yeah thank you very much for spending
some time with us again
pleasure eddie you know i come to
chicago and i don't see my brother you
know that's
i love you man it's your your your
i ask allah to unite our hearts always
on the truth and to gather us with the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
may allah protect you protect your
children
and
guide us always
keep us steadfast
thank you guys for tuning in here to the
dean show we'll see you next time like i
said you can go ahead and grab a free
copy of the quran at the deanshow.com to
learn more about what islam says about
jesus his blessed mother there's a whole
chapter named after her and you can see
and hear more from the source instead of
going to the people who are out there
licking the quran like we saw in the
beginning and doing all this crazy stuff
and all this hate based on ignorance and
projecting what they have in them
of themselves out to you you can come to
us view us here every week watch us here
every week on the dean show we'll see
you next time until then peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
you